[Applause]
there's hard times again in these
streets of our city
but we won't take defeat and we don't
want your pity because this
the evening when this place stood
together that summer
three years ago
[Music]
the suicide bomber did what he did at
the ariana grande concert
a trial has just seen his brother jailed
for a minimum
of 55 years but it's not answered
every question martin hett was one of
the 22 people killed
i lost the ability to be ashamed and i
lost the ability
to have fear however painful a long
inquiry will be
his mother needs it my life feels a bit
like a giant
jigsaw at the moment and it just gives
me those pieces that i need
to complete the picture people say will
this bring you closure
no people say will you draw a line under
it
no there is no line there's nothing
there the security services knew about
salman abadi
but nobody was able to stop him we also
now know that there was a security guard
on duty that night who was told by a
member of the public
that salman abadi was acting
suspiciously
the inquiry will examine how that
information was handled
in the aftermath steve howe was one of
those
outside the arena trying to get in to
help
his wife alison was dead inside
there were loads of people there myself
my sons
you know ambulance men firemen loads of
people wanted to go in that arena and
help that night
and all the police did was stop anybody
going open
because of the information they thought
they had
they thought they had and why it took
him two hours
to realize that you know he was a on his
own
um i don't think it would have helped
allison well i'm sure a lot of people
could have been helped
the inquiry will try to make sense of it
all these years on always remember
never forget
forever manchester choose love
manchester thank you
tom parmenter sky news